cette troisième circonscription de
côte-d'or se divise en quatre cantons
urbains et ruraux
elle regroupe dijon ii et iv traverse
chenôve rejoint quetigny chevigny et
s'étend jusqu'à genlis et la plaine de
saône avec ses 110 mille habitants elle
est l'une des plus industriel du
département
politiquement parlant elle est aussi
celle de l'implosion du parti socialiste
et de l'éparpillement de ses anciens
membres à commencer par la députée
sortante la france a soumises fait même
du bilan de kerra bouziane un premier
argument de caen et surtout la
candidature de kara bouziane qui nous
nous pose un peu problème effectivement
pas ce que nous dit votez pour moi on
sans avoir de programme derrière elle
donc moi je considère qu'un député sans
programme c'est un député sans
responsabilité on sait pas vraiment ce
qu'elle veut défendre à leur semble et
ce sera un électron libre à l'assemblée
donc nous on joue sur la clarté députée
sortante caire à bouziane et donc à
nouveau candidate elle n'a pas été
investi par le ps c'est donc sans
étiquette qu'elle s'est lancé dans la
campagne mais pas forcément dans la
dissidence
je ne m'inscris pas dans une dissidente
je pars libre et indépendante plutôt que
dans la dissidence ce n'est pas contre
contre le parti socialiste que je me
présente mais j'ai toute la légitimité
pour plusieurs raisons la première
région elle concerne déjà la désignation
que j'ai contesté au niveau de mon parti
et vu le mutisme et la légèreté avec
laquelle ils ont traité le sujet j'ai
même porté la faire devant les tribunaux
récent soutien à kara bouziane lucas
métro a retiré sa candidature pour se
rallier craignant un duel à républicain
front national au second tour le front
national avec un électorat
principalement basée à la campagne dans
une circonscription majoritairement
urbaine et qui s'inscrit dans la
continuité du programme présidentiel du
parti
il y avait les 144 propositions de
marine
c'est un projet du gouvernement
maintenant il ya nous notre gouvernement
qui en place qui aura ces trois
propositions nous c'est conforme aux
notes ce sera pas conforme au nôtre
c'est à dire c'est pas forcément de
l'opposition systématique mais je pense
que ça va pas être souvent conforme à ce
qu'on voulait faire on voit qu'il ya une
offre pléthorique à gauche donc all
three vasseur là moi tout ce que
j'espère c'est présent 2e tour puis on
verra
ancienne conseillère régionale ps fadila
khattabi elle a rejoint la république en
marche
enseignante d'anglais dans un centre de
formation elle seule représentante de la
société civile prudente sur la force du
vent qui soufflerait est en poupe depuis
la présidentielle
rien n'est fait je crois qu'il faut être
sur le terrain et expliquer à nos
concitoyens la nécessité de donner une
majorité présidentielle à emmanuel
macron c'est très important si on
souhaite voir le programme qu'il a
promis et bien qu'ils soient mis en
musique
seule anne dillenger conserve
l'étiquette ps étiquette qui pourrait au
regard des résultats de la
présidentielle devenir quelque peu
encombrante
indifférent
personne ne peut bien dire ce qui
sortira des urnes
et puis il ya aussi la notoriété et puis
un projet ya une chose qui est qui est
sûr c'est que je suis à gauche sur ps
constructive et vivifiante peut être
lourde à porter aussi l'étiquette les
républicains absente du second tour de
la présidentielle c'est celle que veut
redorer pascal karras d'elle je pense
pas que ce soit l'étiquette qui soit en
mesure d'apporter j'assume je suis
républicaine j'étais ump j'étais rpr
donc j'assume
la preuve en est même sûr mais affiche
vous le verrez je fais partie de ces
rares qui assume ce qui est lourd à part
porté ce sont les affaires les affaires
d'un système les affaires d'hommes
politiques
et là moi je me sens pas responsable
dans un peu plus d'une semaine
maintenant les électeurs de cette 3e
circonscription ont fait d'un premier
choix
quelques jours encore pour permettre aux
candidats d' intensifier encore leur
présence sur le terrain je vous laisse
découvrir les noms des autres candidats
en présence
ils ne sont plus que 14 au total dans
cette circonscription a brigué les
suffrages des électeurs